93 oh that's like before like I was born
I am 20 years old I am 21 I'm 20 years
old I am 21 years old
I think the first CD I purchased was a
green day one oh that's a tough one
purchase honestly I don't have that many
cities it says I booked I don't know if
it's like the original like MacBook or
what uh it looks kind of like
old-fashioned a little is like this fit
I'm gonna burn this on here in the side
book Wow
no I have nothing I bought like that
first gen I thought this was like camera
equipment the size of it oh my god the
click wheels physical and you want me to
copy one of these songs show crew I know
Sheryl Crow yo Wayne's World
what's Wayne's World Snoop Doggy dog dog
you dial doggy style Beck odelay yeah I
don't know what that is either
I don't know which song I would rip out
of any of these let's get matchbox 20
I'm just going to go with classic Sheryl
Crow how do you open it see I'm doing
pretty well so far I guess I just drag
and drop right onto the music section do
I just drag from the track to the iPod
is that the CDs like this is a CD file
right so we got to change into something
that like an iPod can read so is it not
mp3s are you Spotify now so coming
Spotify for them got this got this iBook
oh I will vet sound when it finishes
good like next box 20 manual labor I
don't know what songs is it on the back
of the kit ah there you go
I think I did it it says do not just
connect so that means it's working
even the cable is like so big everything
is so close even me it's not even touch
screams wait what yeah it's on huh
but I don't even like Snoop Dogg yeah it
works how old is this iPod yeah it's
good I actually think my dad still
houses there is to be behind some glass
you know I'm all for vintage but I don't
think I would carry this around with me
unfortunately